let's talk about cnn my friends we have
the story from axios
cnn plus looks doomed
um where should we get the cake from
yeah you know and when's the party
sunday sunday no for real maybe we can
get chris wallace to bake it for us all
right here's the story my friends from
axios they say warner brothers discovery
has suspended all external marketing
spend for cnn plus and has laid off
cnn's long-time chief financial officer
as it weighs what to do with the
subscription streaming service moving
forward now now hold on everybody was
saying that ten thousand subscribers you
know they ten thousand daily active
users axio says they have 150 000
subscribers so far let me just put that
in some numbers for you if they're
getting between three and six dollars
we're looking at between like what eight
around eight million maybe they're
making per month
now they spent i think 250 million to
set it up so they're deep in the hole
and not going to recover that anytime
soon certainly not as much as they
thought it would be but still a lot of
money that being said my friends if you
think we're better than them please go
to timcast.com members
because um we we should have more than
that we don't yes
but we should
but um
we you know it's it's all grow it's
growth the more members we get the more
people we hire the bigger we get cnn
plus should not be doing as well as
they're doing they are of course they're
still doing so abysmally bad they're
probably going to get nuked do you see
the bottom line of that right there
sources say a plan is being considered
to replace chris cuomo's 9 p.m eastern
prime time slot with a live new cast and
i love how they describe this newscast
instead of a personality driven
perspective programming wow good
yeah perspective programming yeah you
know you know we thought about that too
here at tim cast we were like why have
this tim pool guy host a show with
conversation let's just hire chris cuomo
and have him you know
talk to people that would make way more
i would i would love to have chris cuomo
on if he was like actually talking yeah
yeah you know what i mean this sense so
warner brothers owns cnn they're just
basically pumping massive amounts of
marketing into it to get a hundred
thousand people to subscribe to their
thing but i mean is that that indicates
nothing to whether or not it's good or
valuable yeah it's not good i'm gonna
sorry the issue isn't the 150 000 subs
it's that only 10 000 people on average
use it per day which is like per day
that's 24 hours
so
think about that
in 24 hours about 400 every hour about
400 people or so or is that is that is
that right that's like a that's like an
average telegram chat room
you know kind of thing
i mean i actually do think i have more
people in my telegram chat actively uh
on a regular basis that and i know i do
not market or pay for anything i would
like to see the ratio of other companies
that have subscription models like how
many subscribers tim cast has versus how
many people land on it every day same
with netflix but that's apples to
oranges well you get an idea of the
ratio of how many people actually pay
for it and how many people actually
watch it and that's that number is
pretty important yeah i'm i was gonna
mention this earlier i'm gonna sound
like a broken record here but i still
don't understand how cnn saw that they
were doing abysmally in the ratings and
thought you know what we're gonna get
people to pay for this oh yeah why would
any more stuff i mean like yeah it's
like it's free at the airport that's why
people watch it not anymore yeah they've
been at the airports oh my gosh so
that's all right well maybe that's why
they're doing so far i'll tell you what
happened is they had a meeting and this
is my opinion
and went hey why are ratings so bad
among millennials and some marketing guy
was like because millennials are
watching streaming services and they
were like if we launch a streaming
service we'll get millennials i'll tell
you i bet the real issue is that of
those 150 subscribers
it's like 149 people who are 55 or older
you know what this is like this is like
quibby you remember quibby yeah that
thing that was around for like five
minutes microsoft somehow got three nine
months ago so
the idea was that it was micro streaming
so they're like hey what if and they had
like these short reno 911 episodes those
are actually pretty good but they would
only give you a little bit of it so it
was like what do people love well they
love being on their phones and what else
do they love they love short videos so
let's make a company that's all about
programmed scripted short videos and
deliver it to your phone it was a
complete failure nobody liked it because
that's not organic social media content
right people want either like live form
stuff like this not scripted direct
interaction actual human engagement with
you know like actual humans obviously
ian is you know kind of a robot
questionable in that sense but um but
you know we accept you as you are and
and it was just an abysmal failure
because again you could that was jeffrey
katzenberg by the way it was behind that
um the former dreamworks and disney guy
who you could tell had some meetings say
like what are the kids like today oh
stream video let's do that but on the
phone it'll be great
i thought microsoft is a director
invested into that i could be wrong
about that the reality was that nobody
likes cnn yes that cnn was like maybe
the issue is that we're not in the right
place and now they're probably you know
i hope they cried i hope someone at cnn
like sat there and was just like i
wanted if we made it
but they really just don't like it
that's a good point jack the the modern
media now the whole like one-way media
stream is kind of that's what's dying
off it's turning into a two-way thing if
you can't talk to your subscribers and
vice versa then it's no one wants i
actually really i i don't think that
it's just that it's one way or two-way i
agree that that could have something to
do with it but it's also the fact that
they're an unreliable network they
report garbage they don't have an
interesting perspective that anyone
wants to hear that's a good point
because netflix is one way for the most
part and they're
flying you know
excellent netflix is not fine they're
just no flying oh
today yeah they tanked massively did
anyone figure out why they're losing
subscribers what's happening they're
losing
they're all going to cnn plus yeah like
how are we going to go oh it's taxed
because they can't afford taxes so
people are cutting their subscriptions
probably
no no
we'll get to that in a second but but i
i wanted to throw up a really good
really good text in that kind of
actually uh from a buddy of mine who
children nameless right now um but a guy
i used to work with in my old job if
that makes any sense and it said they
had to lift the airline mandates because
it was becoming too obvious that only li
la new york city and the capital city
still care about covid the rest of the
country has moved on to gas prices and
food shortages and gov employees are
still worried about the flu their
distance from their subjects has become
so far that that to convince them that
it is still a democracy they needed to
drop the mandate
democracy
for democracy folks for democracy well i
think the weird thing is to still see
these blue checked journalists be like
everyone we should start suing the
airlines right you know for what because
they're like you agreed they would be
masked when i got in this plane and now
you're taking them off and it's like
well that was the government yo i looked
up um netflix stock the first story
netflix loses subscribers tanks from cnn
their new competitor ooh
interesting yeah so what are we talking
about masks something yeah but we were
gonna talk about why you know where we
think the subscribers are going from
netflix
and them lifting them and then i was
talking about that yeah yeah we were
talking about masks so the bite
administration by the way this just
broke before the the um the show went
live the body administration has
announced that right now in a midterm
election year they are actually going to
be fighting to reinstate the mass
mandates oh yeah really that's so
federal court so we we have we we have
people who are actively calling for
that's what we're talking about suing uh
airlines because the mass mandates got
lifted the ra
this is all come this all comes together
you were mentioning being out of touch
with their subjects right the cnn is
on in line with this narrative on
twitter which exists among like three
percent of the population
that when the masks come off everyone's
screaming and cheering but cnn is on the
side of like this is really bad you know
people should be upset by this and
regular people are like why would i
watch your show that does not relate to
me who cares well i don't know i mean i
think people not wearing masks is a
threat to our
democracy see that i think i think that
perspective right there for democracy we
need an unelected bureaucratic doctor um
who's never you know been elected to dog
catcher in his life to be making
decisions for all 315 million americans
you know someone who you know be
speckled you know elfish elderly man
that's
true democracy is he still around though
that's true because leaving voicemails
yeah if he if he has he left any
voicemails recently
can we give us an update left there's a
freedom tunes video that reported a
bunch of voicemails he left on msnbc's
answering machines yeah that was good
the idea being that fauci is just out of
the media now for some reason mm-hmm
that's
i'll give the media that much they
recognized fauci is out and he's not
he's like doing the podcast of the kid
who lives next door and stuff
like regular media it's just it's funny
because tim you you sort of mentioned
that actually you know you mentioned
this that in a midterm election year
they're saying they're gonna fight to
reinstate the mandates it is very
bizarre because they've known that
that's a losing issue for a little while
now and everything's going so poorly
it's almost like they're just flailing
around trying to do anything they're not
even thinking strategy when you're that
low in the polls when you're just
sinking you're drowning you're you're
you're flawless
you're not actually making calculated
motions they're like we've got 33 left
how do we destroy the last speaking of
which i can't forget i literally i
uploaded a cartoon about this today you
guys check it out it's called the
democrats brilliant midterm strategy or
the lockdowns are coming back
philadelphia philadelphia brought the
masked mandates back yep and
we'll see i said end of last year the
man the lockdowns are going to come back
luke said they wouldn't it wouldn't
happen i said they would once it started
getting lifted i was like i guess luke
was right i was wrong but now i'm kind
of like
i don't know no i and i i reported this
and people you know got all mad at me
because they were discussing this in the
white house um returning the masks or
excuse me turning the lockdowns that
they
kind of the impetus for that and then
biden was even going to do a whole
speech about it that basically got
flipped into the nationwide vaccine
mandate speech but it was essentially
the same type of rhetoric they just
switched it from lockdowns into vaccines
but this whole idea of you know we're in
this together he keeps they keep talking
about it um ron klain the white house
press um or excuse me the white house
chief of staff keeps referring to this
as like his um you know his fdr moment
everything's his fdr moment right from
this to ukraine to whatever else he's
you know he's the new fdr he's the new
fdr except you can't get anything past
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm we'll see you all there